[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me know when you're done
I'm just here
please welcome he makes Benigni look
like an English teacher I love him
is so cool so great
I do miss Steve Rossi though please
welcome one of the stars of The Cider
House Rules and a guy who just rules
Charlize Theron and Keanu Reeves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
music and movies
a Hollywood marriage that is actually
lasted in the beginning the music came
from an upright piano at the foot of the
screen now it comes from a digitally
enhanced altro stereophonic massively
encoded on spiring city of equipment
hidden above below and around you the
messenger is very complicated but the
message remains simple here are the
nominees for Best Original Score
American Beauty by Thomas Newman
Angela's Ashes by John Williams
[Applause]
The Cider House Rules by Rachel Portman
[Music]
the Red Violin by John koreana
[Applause]
[Music]
the talented mr. Ripley by Gabriella
yeah dead
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to John Corigliano
for the red Bible
[Music]
first roster for John Corigliano and his
second nomination he was nominated in
1980 for scoring altered states
[Music]
I didn't think I was gonna be here and
uh up here and I'm really speechless but
I just want to tell you thanks so much
you know I'm from another world of
classical music and when I write my
symphonies in my concertos it's a very
lonely profession and one thing I've
learned about film writing is how
communal it is and the reason people
give thanks is because there are so many
people that had so much to do with this
film and with the music from Peter Gelb
from Sony classics who introduced me to
Francois Girard the wonderful director
of his film Andy Fishman the producer
but then you have to go to the voice of
the violin and say you know you can
write all the notes you want but if
someone doesn't play them like a god
they'll never sound that way and Joshua
Bell the great violinist played them
like a god Thank You Josh
essa Peka Solomon and all my other
friends and I would like to thank all my
other friends for that thank you so much
[Applause]